plus il existe sur la planète pour
beaucoup d'acteurs tchéquie et sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens
[Musique]
m
et
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs parce que si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
on soit à tous nous sommes ensemble pour
deux heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 14 septembre l'interdiction
des rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes dans les parcs et les plages
interdiction de danse et même dans les
mariages jour jeanne mille personnes
dans les salles de spectacle face aux
contaminations qui se multiplient les
préfet de gironde et des bouches du nord
serre la vis dans leur département et
peut-être strasbourg l'arrêté imposant
le port du masque généralisé est à
nouveau retoqué par le tribunal
administratif
israël va plus loin place or confinement
nationale de trois semaines une semaine
une première dans le monde annonce de ma
gamine et à nier ou qui espèrent juguler
une seconde vague de contamination le
confinement démarrera ce vendredi le
jour de l'an juif israël est le deuxième
pays au monde ayant enregistré le plus
de 4 corona lieuse par habitant au cours
des deux dernières semaines
[Musique]
outremangeurs reprise du procès de
julian assange la justice britannique
doit décider si le co fondateur de
wikileaks doit être extradé vers les
états unis outre atlantique
il risque jusqu'à 175 en prison pour
avoir divulgué à des documents secrets
de l'administration américaine
ses partisans dénoncent eux une
institution qui s'acharne sur un
journaliste le président biélorusse a
rencontré son homologue russe
aujourd'hui à sotchi vladimir poutine
qui se dit convaincu qu'il surmontera la
crise sans toutefois s'avancer
publiquement sur un soutien plus marqué
alexandre loukachenko qui est confirmée
à vladimir poutine vouloir changer la
constitution
une rencontre qui intervient au
lendemain d'une nouvelle manifestation à
minsk contre la réélection de ce dernier
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france et les
derniers chiffres qui nous parviennent
chaque soir 6158 nouveau 4 qu'ovide
confirmé par un test 39 nouveaux foyers
recensés dans les dernières 24 heures
on compte également 34 décès en milieu
hospitalier
face au regain de contamination les
autorités ont donc décidé de prendre de
nouvelles mesures localisées pour la
gironde à bordeaux les journées par
exemple du patrimoine seront annulés et
dix personnes maximum sont autorisés à
circuler dans les parcs
idem dans les bouches du rhône est les
mesures sanitaires sont renforcés comme
en gironde lisation de porter le masque
dans 27 villes
interdiction également de danse et même
dans les mariages
a marseille la foire internationale a
été annulée elle préconise
l'accompagnement pas la répression selon
elle respectait la distanciation
physique reste ce suffisant
dans les rues à haute fréquentation dans
les centres villes les centres
commerciaux
le port du masque doit être obligatoire
dans les espaces aérés où l'on est seul
il n'y a pas de risque avéré si en
sortant de la mairie je vais me baigner
seul après 20 heures
je ne pense pas présenter un risque de
transmission du virus
en ce qui concerne la vie privée
je demande solennellement à chaque
habitant de la métropole de limiter les
rassemblements familiaux et festif à 10
personnes maximum
je pense en particulier au mariage il ne
s'agit pas de ne plus se marier mais de
reporter les grandes fêtes liées au
mariage
et alors que dans leurs locaux vides à
19 a déjà pu être plus de
2 9021 921 1000 personnes le directeur
de la branche européenne de l'om est
prévient octobre et novembre seront je
cite plus dures en europe avec une
mortalité plus élevé et pas de
confinement nationale donc en france
tout du moins pour l'instant mais des
mesures qui se durcissent localement
comme on vient de le voir d'où le thème
de notre débat ce soir face au co vide
doit-on siffler la fin de la récréation
pour en parler nous sommes avec alex
ripoull un éditorialiste bonsoir alexis
poulain merci d'être avec nous c'est que
tu es eric venet contributeurs pour
atlantico point fr bonsoir eric
verhaegue merci d'être avec nous et
également alors un mois pour commencer
sur les mesures annoncées par parler
préfet on les a entendu les
manifestations de grande ampleur annuler
ces prochaines semaines notamment dans
les bouches-du-rhône pas de
rassemblement statique sur les plages on
danse plus pendant les mariages ça va
être gay qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça
va être efficace au gouvernement a bien
fait de délégués de rejeter entre
guillemets la responsabilité au préfet
éric vague non mais moi je pense en
effet que le gouvernement a pris des
mesures pour éviter de s'exposer à cette
critique qu'on entendait monter dans la
société civile
selon laquelle il utilisé le prétexte du
coc vide pour imposer des mesures
liberticides et je pense qu'avec un
certain bon sens jean castex et emmanuel
macron ont compris qu'il y avait une
limite à tout et que notamment interdire
dans un certain nombre de rues isolé
michel ribeiro la lui disais à marseille
interdire dans certains des lieux isolés
le la circulation libre est quelque
chose qui pose problème puisque les gens
ne comprennent pas pourquoi alors qu'il
n'y a aucun risque avéré de
contamination dans tel ou tel endroit il
devrait porter le masque
maintenant il faut reconnaître quand
même que cette ambiance anxiogène lui
gouvernement l'utilisent le gouvernement
n'hésite pas trop à dire ayez peur
faites attention
alors je peux comprendre pourquoi il le
dit notamment par principe de précaution
mais on voit bien que nous sommes dans
une ambiance où la peur est aujourd'hui
utilisée pour gouverner et pour
justifier un certain nombre de
modifications substantielles
on va utiliser ce langage administratif
dans le mode de vie courant des français
et notamment à un certain nombre de
modifications substantielles dans nos
libertés publiques qui pose un problème
en france et ailleurs on a vu notamment
en allemagne un certain de manifestation
venant de gens qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec cette façon de limiter nos libertés
au nom d'un coronavirus qu'on a du mal à
voir dans les rues et eric verhaegue est
assez en phase avec cette tribune est
publiée dans mediapart
nous ne voulons plus être gouvernés par
la peur nous disent 35 chercheurs
universitaires médecins qui critiquent
la communication du gouvernement
justement qu'il juge trop anxiogène vous
vous partagez alexis poulain ce
diagnostic cet avis d'eric verhaeghe et
ses 35 chercheurs
oui le problème c'est que le
gouvernement n'a pas préparé cette
rentrée ou très mal et que du coup il
joue sur deux tableaux la peur d'un côté
en disant attention la co responsabilité
en disant nous ne sommes pas
responsables vous êtes tous responsables
et attention si vous ne faites pas ce
qu'on vous demande où ce qu'on nous
demande peu finalement
vous serez responsable de l'hécatombe
qui pourrait venir
et puis l'autre c'est la répression
c'est les amendes c'est de dire on va
continuer à mettre des amendes pour ceux
qui ne portent pas correctement leurs
masques même si parfois porter un masque
ça n'a aucun sens comme le disait la
mère de marseille ça ne sert à rien de
dire que je vais être contagieuse si je
suis seul à 20 heures sur la plage mais
malheureusement les lois liberticides
s'accumulent s'amoncellent dans un
délire bas de la surenchère parce que
finalement l'idée c'est de dire on doit
avoir le plus petit dénominateur commun
pour que tout le monde obéit donc la
peur d'un marché et puis ensuite on va
faire des lois pour dire aux gens
arrêtez de faire des réunions familiales
arrêté de danser arrêté de chanter jouer
les anniversaires c'est un projet du
commis de partout
on rentre dans le foyer des gens on est
en train vraiment de responsabiliser
même de faire un vrai un choc
psychologique auprès des français en les
rendant responsables même coupable de
faire n'importe quoi face à ce virus
alors que on n'en sait rien je me
pardonnez moi mais si je peux me
permettre ça c'est justement pas le
gouvernement le gouvernement s'est bien
gardé de dalles et voilà punir il est
plutôt parti dans la responsabilité des
uns et des autres et il a laissé la
patate chose si j'ose dire aux régions
et notamment aux entrées des faits après
vous allez pas raté l'épisode où
emmanuel macron a nommé une quinzaine de
nouveaux préfets les préfets sont là
pour simplement être les apôtres est
victime en faire le sale boulot pour que
ce ne soit pas les ministres qui sont
responsables qui soit responsable
in fine et donc c'est une manoeuvre
politique personne est trop dur c'est
aussi l'idée de dire c'est au territoire
cher à jean castex de gérer eux mêmes
alors petit niveau à leur grand niveau
en fonction de ce qu'il voit sur le
terrain pour que la réponse soit adaptée
à chaque situation locale et pour que le
vilain grands mots du grand rond
confinement nationale ne soit prononcée
par personne parce que personne ne veut
le dire
l'économie est à plat parce qu'il ya eu
deux mois de confinement alors sans
doute c'est ce qu'il fallait faire le
virus circule s étaient extrêmement
dangereux et on n'avait pas de lit en
réanimation mais qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que tous
les lits qui ont été écrits en urgence
n'ont pas été pérennisée on se retrouve
finalement dans les mêmes problématiques
qu'au mois de mars
donc rien n'a été appris on a maintenant
des masques bora tant mieux surtout pour
les gens en première ligne des soignants
qui ont réclamé au mois de mars mais on
n'est pas plus avancés au niveau des
services de réanimation et ça c'est
extrêmement inquiétant les rs continuent
dans leur travail de supprimer délit
plutôt que d'avoir prévu en dix ans
cette crise de la pandémie elle est loin
d'être finie or en a fait à partir du
mois de mai comme si c'était derrière
nous alors alexis avant de faire réagir
eric verhaegue jeu
voudrais vous faire justement écouter
didier rahout sur ce thème justement est
ce qu'on en fait trop ou est ce qu'on
perd pied
égouttez le professeur marseillais il
faut faire attention dans les positif
actuel il y a bien entendu des cas il y
a plus de cas qu'il n'y en avait il ya
trois semaines en moi mais il ya aussi
plus de gens tester il y actuellement
beaucoup de faux positifs à eric
verhaegue c'est intéressant nous
explique entre les inc en gros c'est la
pagaille la panique ont partagé oui oui
je pense qu'un invité aujourd'hui il ya
un vrai flou dans les statistiques
je me souviens de martin hirsch qui est
le directeur général de de l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris qui est au
moins d'août de mémoire ou juillet je ne
sais plus nous étions au mois d'août
nous expliquer qu'il y avait en gros
toutes les toutes les semaines un
triplement du nombre de cas en
réanimation est en réalité personne n'a
jamais vu de statistiques
corroborant cette affirmation donc on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui un discours
officiel très alarmiste et on s'aperçoit
quand on étudie les chiffres quand on
regarde les choses à tête reposée de
façon objective n'ont ni rationnel que
on ne sait pas trop on sait pas trop il
n'y a pas de chiffres on sait pas
exactement
il n'y a pas de partage de données qui
soient claires et qui soit satisfaisant
en termes de délibération démocratique
donc aujourd'hui moi je comprends que
didier raoul disent non c'est pas on
nous parle de beaucoup de choses on est
très alarmés son signe des chiffres mais
on n'a pas tirer ça au clair
moi ce que je crois c'est qu'en effet
aujourd'hui il y a une espèce de de
coïncidences entre cette peur du virus
qui existe et le virus a tué le virus
tue et c'est une réalité et une
l'utilisation qu'on en fait à des fins
politiques notamment pour convaincre les
gens de se résigner de suivre des
comportements de d'obéissance de
docilité où plus personne ne voit
exactement quel est l'objectif
scientifique
l'objectif sanitaire de cette visée
politique et je crois que emmanuel
macron commis une grande erreur en
utilisant la peur pour gouverner parce
il a beaucoup critiqué ce qu'ils disent
ce qu'ils taxaient d'utiliser les
émotions à l'extrême droite notamment
marine le pen il aimait tous ces gens là
utilisent les peurs les émotions pour
essayer d'arriver au pouvoir et on
s'aperçoit qu'en vérité emmanuel macron
est le premier producteur d'émotion
manipulatrice pour eux vous pour
infantiliser sont pas sûrs que nous eric
verhaegue quand même un yaya israël
aujourd'hui ans qui nous a annoncé voilà
qui confinait à partir de vendredi
lexie poulain voilà on est on à la
version encore lightan si j'ose dire en
france
mais attention israël est un très petit
pays donc c'est comme si vous disiez
qu'on re confinait une région ou un
département donc cela il ya aussi la
façon du territoire la taille du
territoire et puis c'est la fête c'est
une fête sur le nouvel an donc beaucoup
de rencontres beaucoup de rendez vous
sociaux donc on re confine site virus
est là à noël vous j'attends de voir
quelle va être la réaction des autorités
françaises mais ce qu'on ait droit à un
recond finement territoriales qui
parfaire l'ensemble du territoire
national mais on ne dira jamais de
confinement nationale et il faut voir
quels sont le cil et les périmètres de
ce confinement j'ai pas les détails
malheureusement mais évidemment on peut
dire que c'est pire mais regardez nos
voisins l'allemagne
ils font tout autant de tests nous il ya
autant de cas avérés mais finalement
c'est beaucoup mieux géré en corée
discipline et alexis poulain allait
réellement un symbole au hadj diouf
c'est déjà ça mais bon les fesses et
soumise aux pays qui font du télétravail
font attention
non c'est faux de dire ça je crois que
les français sont extrêmement
disciplinés les armes pour des idiots
alors ils ont été primés pour des idiots
pour les mal-logés mars à hier les
images on les avait vus comme nous et
oui mais mais bon il dès que le store y
en a partout mais regardez surtout on
dit aux gens attention dans vous rendez
vous familiaux vous devez être que 10
et puis on en voit des gamins faire la
rentrée universitaire dans les facs
bondé et c'est là où ce sont les vrais
foyers de contamination
donc on se fiche du monde en fait en
train de rendre les gens malades mais
malade psychologiquement en les
empêchant d'avoir une vie personnelle
une vie intime et finalement les
obligeant d'aller se mettre dans des
dans des clusters organes
que ce soit les écoles que ce soit les
universités les bureaux les transports
en commun enfin regardez là le brouillon
totale qu'est ce que ce gestion de la
crise en france
j'ai vu ça nulle part ailleurs peut-être
un peu en grande bretagne où ça a été
assez brouillon aussi mais honnêtement
on est nul les autorités sont nuls
elles font passer ça sous le couvert de
les français sont nuls non les autorités
n'ont pas préparé la rentrée
universitaire me scolaire c'est clair ça
se voit maintenant aujourd'hui les profs
l'on dit longtemps avant on a dit c'est
des feignants ils n'ont pas fait leur
boulot encore une fois c'était leur
faute
non c'est à un moment il fallait
organiser la rentrée avec des moyens
c'est-à-dire des classes beaucoup
beaucoup plus légère de l'aération
systématique dans les lieux qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas serré voir comment faire
tout ça n'a pas été pensé en amont sur
la la gestion aussi des enfants
que font les parents si leur enfant est
positif et ce qu'ils doivent rester à la
maison alors on est en train de
réfléchir mais c'est de l'improvisation
permanente et il faudrait faire passer
ça sous le coup de la gestion formidable
alors non moi je suis désolé je tombe
pas dans le panneau
je pense qu'on est nombreux à ne pas
tomber dans le panneau c'est de
l'improvisation et c'est très mal fait
eric avait règle le problème principal
n'est t'il pas les tests quand on voit
effectivement quand on tousse etc
on est supposé rester chez soi vie jour
se faire tester on sait pas quand on
peut prendre rendez vous il faut
respecter un certain délai et une fois
qu'on a la chance d'avoir subi les coups
villon dans les biens on doit attendre
entre trois et cinq jours
rubis dans cette et ironique je confirme
non je pense que le passage l'écouvillon
est très douloureux ce que je ne suis
resté en france un éviter qu'on
recommande vivement rien jours
d'ailleurs on expliquera le pourquoi on
n'a pas approfondi la tête la
possibilité d'un test sanguin ou la
teste là d'un test salivaire qui sont
beaucoup moins douloureux et beaucoup
moins intrusif et on demandera
l'institut pasteur des raisons pour
lesquelles on n'a pas fait fleurir cette
possibilité mais moi ce que je crois
c'est surtout que le gouvernement a bien
conscience que 1 re confinement serait
dramatique pour le pays c'est à dire que
il nous ferait définitivement basculé
dans le besoin dans le dans un rang de
pays de seconde zone économiquement qui
nous ferait perdre toute crédibilité
internationale et que face à ce risque
on est en train aujourd'hui de chercher
à ménager la chèvre et le chou en
expliquant que certes il faut tester
certes il faut être précautionneux mais
qu'en même temps il ne faut quand même
pas nuire à la productivité et à
l'efficacité économique et aujourd'hui
peillon moi je retiens une seule chose
de de cette situation c'est que le
gouvernement comprend que le pays est
aux abois et que aujourd'hui
économiquement nous sommes au bord du
gouffre et nous sommes au bord d'une
implosion d'un effondrement
international complet notamment par
rapport à des pays qui nous mordent les
mollets en termes de produit intérieur
brut en valeur absolue zir l'inde un
certain nombre de pays qui sont en phase
d'expansion la france est aujourd'hui
affaiblie et nous savons tous que si
leur confinement avaient lieu de
viendrions la 10e la 15e 20e puissance
mondiale et que face à ce risque absolu
qui sera irréversible ne reviendrons pas
sur le devant de la scène avant des
générations et des générations ou face à
ce risque absolu on essaye de ménager la
chèvre et le chou et au lieu de dire aux
français
rae
jc mettez vous au travail pour relever
le pays on leur explique tout ira bien
mais en même temps fait attention et
soyez pas trop excentrique
je pense que cet hymne est requise là on
l'appellera cher merci en tout cas
alexis poulin et eric verhaegue d'avoir
accepté ce décryptage nous avoir donné
un autre point de vue merci à vous deux
et en espagne à des autorités et la
population reste toujours sous tension
eux aussi en rapport avec ce virus ont
fait le point barcelone avec notre
correspondante sur place les sea king là
ici les experts médicaux et les
responsables politiques n'hésitent pas à
parler de seconde vague
l'espagne est l'un des pays européens où
circule le plus le virus le nombre de
contagion continuent d'augmenter
fortement entre 7000 et 8000 cas par
jour ont été comptabilisées la semaine
dernière alors à madrid les centres de
santé publique se disent stature et les
médecins doivent gérer entre 50 et 60
patients par jour
et du côté des hôpitaux ils dénoncent
aussi un manque de personnel et la
multiplication du nombre de patients à
temps du peut vite 19
ils ont triplé depuis le mois de juillet
dernier alors pour les syndicats les
conditions de travail sont même précaire
et convoque une grève à partir du 28
septembre dans les centres de santé
madrilène alors cette inquiétude se
répercute sur la population alors que
les enfants ont commencé le retour à
l'école ou depuis la semaine dernière
mais toutefois la situation actuelle
reste incomparable avec celle vécue au
mois de mars en espagne il ya environ
actuellement 34 morts par jour nous
sommes donc bien loin des 900 quotidien
au pic de l'épidémie
après la deuxième vague de kobe 19
commence donc à prendre forme plusieurs
pays en sont victimes notamment israël
l'état hébreu qui est donc le premier
d'entre eux avoir réimposer un
confinement de trois semaines les
explications avec valentin carpentier
elle était redoutée elle est finalement
sur le point d'arriver
la deuxième vague de kobe 19 se profile
à travers le monde
après un bilan de plus de neuf cent
vingt mille morts et 29 millions de
personnes contaminées pour anticiper une
aggravation de la crise sanitaire
certains états prennent les devants
deuxième pays au monde avec le plus de
cas par habitant enregistrées sur les
deux dernières semaines
israël a décidé d'instaurer un
confinement nationale de trois semaines
une décision prise par le premier
ministre netanyahu aujourd'hui lors de
la réunion du gouvernement
nous avons pris une décision sur le plan
strict de confinement pour trois
semaines encore avec une possibilité de
prolongation vu au bras mais chut mm ce
jeudi ils ont agité un drapeau rouge
les cadres du ministère de la santé et
directeurs d'hôpitaux nous ont averti
que les taux de mortalité impose
l'application de mesures immédiates
une partie du personnel médical et des
hôpitaux est débordé les autorités ont
annoncé que ce confinement obligatoires
entrera en vigueur ce vendredi jour du
nouvel an juif
il prendra fin au mieux aux alentours du
9 octobre ce qui fait débat puisque les
fête juive de yom kippour et souccot
auront lieu durant cette période
d'isolement
le premier ministre israélien a tout de
même précisé que les prières avec 10
personnes maximum seront autorisés dans
les lieux fermés et 20 personnes maximum
dans les lieux ouverts depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire
israël a recensé plus de 1120 morts et
près de 150 mille cas de kobe de 19 et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis tel aviv avec steven ravive
journaliste indépendante
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir sivan ravive merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
comment réagit-on cette annonce d'euros
confirmant en israël sachant évidemment
qu'on est en pleine fête dans le pays
la situation a empiré au cours des
dernières semaines depuis l'été nous
nous dirigions effectivement vers un
confinement de trois semaines ce qui ne
plaît pas du tout aux israéliens il ya
beaucoup de frustration
les gens voulaient revenir à la vie
normale ce qui était le cas au cours de
l'été et la situation les force à
revenir chez eux à se confiner chez eux
à reprendre à un mode de vie extrêmement
strictes les forces à éviter les
synagogues pendant les fêtes religieuses
pour ce confinement qui va a commencé
vendredi 18 septembre qui est également
le nouvel an juif c'est vraiment la
grande fête juive dans le monde et
ensuite tu joues au plus tard ce sera le
yom qui couvre une période très
importante de célébration religieuse
pour les juifs et ses règles ses
règlementations forceront les citoyens à
rester chez eux à éviter les synagogues
en tout cas quelques personnes seulement
pourront se rassembler en même temps il
n'y aura pas de célébration avec la
famille étendue et tout cela bien sûr
des conséquences économiques les
commerces fermeront tourisme intérieur
va
être étouffé les écoles seront fermées
les restaurants également l'épicière
donc il y aura vraiment des fermetures
très étendu ce qui ne plaît pas aux
israéliens
certains comprennent qu'un sur
l'importance et les avantages en matière
de santé mais beaucoup critiquent
fortement le gouvernement
comment justement on explique dans
l'état hébreu cette recrudescence du
virus à c'est l'un des pires records
après bahreïn en termes de contamination
comment explique-t-on israël avait
plutôt bien géré cette crise sauf erreur
de ma part jusqu'à présent on peut
étudier la situation selon deux points
de vue tout d'abord israël a été l'un
des premiers pays à mettre en place un
événement
on a fermé les frontières on a un
gardien il les visites d'étrangers et le
confinement à fonctionner à l'époque on
s'est retrouvé avec un nombre de cas et
par joueur 2 0 et donc la vie est
revenue au mode ordinaire mais on va
certaines personnes pensent que sami la
vie est redevenue normale un peu trop
rapidement les israéliens agissait comme
si rien n'était arrivé et certaines
personnes ne respectait pas tout les
rêves ne portait pas correctement leurs
masques ne respectez pas tout à fait la
distanciation physique une raison et
l'autre raison c'est le nombre de tests
il y a quelques mois en israël on a
testé quelques milliers de personnes par
jour aujourd'hui on est beaucoup plus on
parle de 40 mille tests par jour bien
sûr cela signifie qu on enregistre plus
de cas confirmés
donc cela pourrait également expliquer
en partie la situation aujourd'hui en
tant qu'observatrice est ce que cette
situation sanitaire en israël
justifie mesure aussi strict quelle est
la situation à ce que vous avez des
hôpitaux qui sont engorgés comme on a pu
le voir dans les pays européens ce qui a
justifié
d'ailleurs le confinement je disais
quelle est la situation sanitaire en
israël est ce que les hôpitaux par
exemple sont sont engorgés la situation
a très certainement empirer à adel
auparavant on avait quelques centaines
de jours de cas par jour est maintenant
l'un voit de plus en plus jusqu'à 4000
cas par jour la situation empire donc de
façon exponentielle
nous n'avons pas encore de pénurie de
matériel de ventilateurs mais le
problème se pose pour le personnel
médical
ils pourraient être submergées c'est
bien c est à ne plus être en mesure de
gérer la situation le nombre de cas et
le nombre de patients au jour le jour
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement on essaye de ralentir
l'épidémie avec le confinement merci
beaucoup sylvaner à vivre journaliste
indépendant d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants un nous parlerons
de julian assange aujourd'hui s'ouvre et
à londres la deuxième phase de
l'audience un jeu britannique décidera
au terme de celle ci
si oui ou non le lanceur d'alerté sera
extradé vers les états unis
et puis direction la biélorussie
annuaire poutine et alexandre
loukachenko se sont rencontrés
aujourd'hui onu de son côté accepte un
débat d'urgence
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
peut-être un coup politique n'a jamais
été obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soir vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire les bêtes des idées courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de grignan aujourd'hui une gauche plus
très bien ce musée tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france
reprise du procès de julian assange à
londres la justice britannique doit
trancher est-ce que le co fondateur de
wikileaks doit être extradé vers les
états unis les américains l'accusent d'
observer d'espionnage pour avoir dévoilé
les documents confidentiels de
l'administration quentin mauclair un
procès extrêmement attendu lundi dernier
julian assange a fait sa première
apparition publique depuis le mois de
février après avoir déclaré son identité
l'australien de 49 ans a officiellement
déclaré qu'il ne consentait pas à son
extradition
une procédure que l'ensemble de ses
soutiens exclut également la force de
cette communauté et la force du système
judiciaire du royaume uni et la vigueur
de la frontière autour de la vie
nationale ici dépendront de la direction
que prendra cette affaire même si julian
ne se fait pas extradé alors je suppose
que la force du royaume uni et de son
système judiciaire seront un exemple
pour le monde
mardi c'est une représentante d'une
organisation anti torture qui a été
appelé à la barre pour témoigner contre
les états unis
un professeur en journalisme a ensuite
été auditionnés ils étaient malmenés par
le procureur mais les avocats de la
défense ont finalement été stoppé le
témoignage de marc feld stein s'est
préoccupé de la surprise de l'acte
d'accusation contre julian c'est la
première fois qu'un éditeur est inculpé
ja aspen
[Applaudissements]
enfin jeudi à la surprise générale le
procès un singe s'est fait rattraper par
la situation sanitaire actuelle en
raison d'un cas suspect de covin 19
l'audience a été ajournée ce procès
devrait durer encore deux semaines à
minima pour rappel si julian assange est
extradé vers les états unis
il risque une peine deux cent soixante
quinze ans de prison et nous sommes
justement avec antoine veil l'avocat de
julian assange bonsoir antoine mais
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors tous les regards sont
désormais tournés vers la justice
britannique c'est une décision
extrêmement délicate à prendre pour le
juge avant justement d'en parler
première question comment va julian
assange
c'est la question qui revient en boucle
parce que tout le monde prend la mesure
du fait que n'ayant reçu absolument
aucune visite depuis le mois de mars ni
ses proches ni ses avocats ayant été
dans un état que le rapporteur des
nations unies a décrit comme de la
torture psychologique et qui caractérise
un état on va dire de santé absolument
affreux atroce tant psychologiquement
que physiquement il est très diminué
on sait déjà que il est dans un état de
santé qui ne lui permet pas de se
défendre utilement ni pour le moment en
grande bretagne eni dans l'éventualité
d'un procès aux états unis donc son état
de santé véritablement au coeur des
débats
et on peut s'étonner que la communauté
internationale et l'angleterre en
premier lieu n'en prennent pas acte pour
ordonner rapidement des mesures qui
permettent de sauvegarder la santé de da
seront alors on le disait une décision
extrêmement délicate à prendre pour le
juge qui va être évidemment très
observés selon vous est ce que ce jeu
j'ai les moyens aujourd'hui de
travailler en toute indépendance et en
toute sérénité est ce que la justice est
clairement sous pression selon l'avocat
que vous êtes l avocat que je suis il
est comme tous les gens qui soutiennent
assange s'est il espère que les critères
de droit vont prospérer vont permettre
de faire barrière à la demande des états
unis
les critères de droit c'est d'abord de
démontrer qu'il s'agit d'un procès
politique
et la deuxième chose c'est de dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'état de santé d'assange
et les charges qu'il a depuis des années
par les états unis ne permettent pas
l'extradition
maintenant ce qui nous fait douter et ce
qui nous fait craindre c'est une
succession de signaux très négatif
la première c'est comme je voulais dit
qu'il n'a plus accès à des avocats
depuis le mois de mars la seconde est le
père de julien assange l'évoqué à
l'instant c'est qu'il ya à peu près dix
jours on a découvert un nouvel acte
d'accusation dans une affaire qui date
depuis 2010 ça veut dire que les charges
si vous voulez sont assez peu établi
pour que dix jours avant l'ouverture
d'un procès sur des faits d'il ya dix
ans on découvre des nouveaux éléments
assange n'a jamais pu prendre
connaissance de l'intégralité de son
dossier
donc si vous voulez des éléments comme
ça il y en a énormément qui nous font
dire que oui on a peut-être une justice
qui est un peu sous pression et un
pouvoir politique britannique qui comme
tous les autres pouvoirs du monde en
fait à peut-être du mal à s'opposer aux
états unis est un processus qui nous ne
nous paraît plus du tout juridique mais
est devenu il ya déjà bien longtemps
éminemment politique aujourd'hui vous
craignez clairement que la raison d'état
se substitue aux droits en l'espèce mais
déjà il ya un précédent qui nous choque
qui est le précédent de chelsea manning
donc dans le cas de chelsea manning qui
vous rappellent celles à la personne qui
a été inculpée et condamnée pour avoir
dit
hugues et les informations
confidentielles dont assange aurait
permis si on en croit l'acte
d'accusation américain le piratage
même si on comprend pas et on n'est
jamais vraiment compris quels éléments
matériels justifierait c'est ce piratage
mais il est clair que depuis le début de
cette affaire
on a passé si vous voulez le stade
juridique et qu' ils les pressions qu'il
subit les surveillances qu'il subit
l'internement qu'il subit isolement
qu'il subit sont un traitement tout à
fait exceptionnel qui pour être clair
n'appartient pas à la sphère judiciaire
classique donc nous espérons
véritablement et c'est là on va dire la
dernière chance parce que s'il est
extradé après sur le sol américain
plus personne d'autre que les américains
ne pourront faire quelque chose donc on
espère certainement un sursaut populaire
mais aussi surtout un sursaut de la
justice justement vous espèrent un
sursaut populaire mais vous condamner le
peu de résonance aux collectives dans
cette affaire dans le monde francophone
notamment pourquoi selon vous ce peu de
résonance et ça fait aussi partie de la
stratégie qui a été conduite contre
assange à savoir qu'on a indûment
complexifier son dossier en le faisant
passer pour tout un tas de choses qu'il
n'est pas aujourd'hui comme l'a rappelé
son père assange et doit être considérée
comme un éditeur de presse c'est pas lui
qui donne les informations il fait que
les publier et à ce titre là il doit
bénéficier d'une protection très
particulière mais pourquoi pas de
mobilisation déjà parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas que c'est peut-être pas
un dossier qui intéresse seulement les
états unis je rappelle que c'est assange
qui a permis notamment de
de mettre la lumière sur le fait que les
présidents français étaient espionnés
par les services secrets américains
donc c'est un dossier qui a des
ramifications dans le monde francophone
mais par la complexité des faits par des
campagnes négatives qui ont été
conduites contre assange
et puis par une indifférence générale
parce qu'il ya peut-être un déficit
d'information il est vrai que on a dans
le monde francophone à mon avis une
attention qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux de ce procès alors ce qui
pourrait aussi le sauver c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des carnets dé du débat
julian assange mène des activités
journalistiques ou non c'est à cette
question qu'il faudra répondre puisqu'il
devrait être protégé dans ce cas de
figure les médias aussi n'aurait pas
dans ce cas précis joue une forme de
solidarité avec lui il a un rapport de
toute façon très ambiguë avec beaucoup
de choses les médias en sont une
l'opinion publique on est une autre
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
voulu se laisser enfermer dans une boîte
qui est assez provocateur sur certains
aspects qui a manqué de soutien
institutionnel mais je tiens à rappeler
quand même que les informations de
wikileaks était publié conjointement
avec tous les plus grands médias
internationaux français allemand anglais
espagnol est ce qu'il ya un seul
journaliste de ces médias qui a été
accusé et est-ce qu'il ya un seul
journaliste qui aurait fait ce qu'on
reproche à assange qui serait espionner
isolé traité comme le dernier des
terroristes j'ai dit souvent que avant
même d'avoir été jugé il a été dépouillé
de tous ses droits
même les plus élémentaires droit de voir
ses proches etc etc
donc c'est vrai qu'on est un petit peu
étonné de ne pas avoir un sursaut du
monde journalistique pour le protéger
parce que si lui est extradé et condamné
alors le simple fait de diffuser des
informations dont personne ne conteste
qu'elles sont vraies et d'intérêt public
deviendra dangereux et que les droits
démocratiques ne pourront plus être
normalement exercée si l'information est
finalement filtrer par le pouvoir en
place quel que soit la décision lui
nello paris parti pourra faire appel ça
veut dire que julian assange risque fort
de rester là où il est
ça risque de prendre encore beaucoup de
temps vous le craignez non parce que le
système britannique fait que l'appel
n'est pas un appel comme nous nous
l'entendons dans le système français
notamment
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut pas
imaginer que l'audience qui va se
dérouler au puy se déroule en ce moment
est une audience on va dire de chauffe
en réalité c'est l'audience principal
qui risquent de déterminer son sort et
le juge d'appel vérifiera évidemment la
régularité de certaines choses mais il
ne sera pas un juge de 2e ressort comme
nous nous en avons l'habitude
donc il faut véritablement que chacun
prenne la mesure de ce qui se passe et
que effectivement la justice soit pas
sous pression
l'enjeu est d'avoir une justice libre
mais soit observée et que l'on puisse
dire si la décision de l'extrader prise
que c'est une décision qui de toute
façon est une décision qui viole les
droits fondamentaux d'assange est donc à
partir du moment où il sera extradé on
est déjà dans un processus qui est un
processus qui n'est plus juridique et je
pense que face à ça il faut que les
démocraties notamment européennes
puissent tenir tête aux états unis et
demander que s'il doit être jugé le soit
dans un cadre différent avec des
garanties beaucoup beaucoup plus forte
merci beaucoup antoine veil avocat de
julian assange un de nous avoir accordé
cet entretien en direct sur rt france
merci m
lahlimi poutine le président russe a
reçu aujourd'hui à sotchi alexandre
loukachenko une rencontre qui intervient
au lendemain d'une nouvelle
manifestation à minsk contre la
réélection du président biélorusse qui a
confirmé à vladmir poutine vouloir
changer la constitution
les deux pays comptent dorénavant
travailler ensemble la russie devrait
accorder un prêt d'1 25 milliard de
dollars à la biélorussie
les exercices militaires communs doivent
commencer dès aujourd'hui et côté
justement delà des mires poutine et
alexandre loukachenko et nous
considérons que la biélorussie est notre
partenaire le plus proche notre allié le
plus proche et c'est ce que nous nous
sommes dit
au téléphone et nous avons encore répété
que nous respecterons tous nos
engagements tous les engagements
qu'elles nous avons souscrit et en 1992
et en 1994 et en tout cas en 1995 vous
étiez vous déjà président moi non mais
cela n'a aucune importance qui est
important c'est que les autres états la
russie a pris des engagements comme je
les dis et indépendamment de la personne
qui est au pouvoir à ce moment là le
pays doit remplir ses obligations
mais c'est dans le chagrin le convoi qui
est notre vrai ami et pour nous c'est
une journée sont un bon les sens et tout
comme pour d'autres républiques
on va en parler au centre de le tc et
d'autres organisations je pense que ma
déclaration au centre de ces
organisations sera bien intéressante
nous avons toujours évaluer et réévaluer
la situation
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
club blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir que donc maison
merci d'être avec nous alors que peut-on
retenir de cette rencontre entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko
le premier point c'est que voulait dire
que monsieur loukachenko a voulu
ostensiblement se placer sous la
protection de la lumière poutine et qui
lui a dit et répété qu'il était le
dernier rempart pour protéger la russie
alors vladimir poutine a semble-t-il
répondu qui lui faisait toute confiance
puisqu'il était un homme politique
expérimenté au pouvoir depuis 1994
c'est-à-dire depuis 26 ans bien plus
longtemps que vladimir poutine lui-même
et qu'il faisait toute confiance pour
résoudre ce problème qui est un problème
interne à la biélorussie donc avec
l'idée que c'est à la biélorussie de le
résoudre
y compris par le référendum puisque
monsieur loukachenko a évoqué cette
hypothèse à minsk il y a quelques jours
en l'assortissant d'ailleurs de
conditions et évidemment on peut
s'interroger sur la crédibilité de
monsieur loukachenko crème là puisqu'au
cours des dernières années il a beaucoup
louvoyé il a accepté en 2010 est à près
de 20 millions d'euros pour la
biélorussie au titre de la coopération
avec les pays d'europe centrale que
proposait et bruxelles
il a aussi refusé avec une grande
constance de mettre en vigueur le traité
qui prévoyait une sorte de fusion entre
la russie et la biélorussie qui
prévoyait d'établir une confédération
avec une fusion d'un certain nombre de
secteurs et en décembre encore lors
d'une rencontre avec le président
biélorusse monsieur poutine a dit mais
il n'ya même pas 90% de du contenu de ce
traité qu'ils soient mises en oeuvre par
la biélorussie et je me demande bien
pourquoi
alors quelle est la situation économique
du bélarus provenant qu'on comprenne le
contexte le bélarus et un est un petit
état d'environ 10 millions d'habitants
qui pourraient avoir une économie
beaucoup plus dynamique qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
en effet il ya des ingénieurs très
compétents des gens très compétents dans
le domaine du numérique et des gens très
dynamiques qui sont en état de créer des
entreprises
seulement voilà le problème c'est que
monsieur le cachet connaît pas un
informateur qui l'a reçu l'économie de
la biélorussie en héritage en 2000 en
1994 et que à l'époque c'était une
économie néo soviétique et dont le fond
pas grand chose a changé depuis cette
époque c'est-à-dire depuis 26 ans le
secteur public représente 70% de
l'économie ça d'ailleurs des avantages
parce que il ya peu de chômage
et puis ça permet à monsieur loukachenko
qui a transformé il ya deux ans tous les
contrats à durée indéterminée en contrat
à durée déterminée d'exercer une
pression sur les gens qui travaillent
dans ces entreprises publiques et
lorsqu'ils sont mécontents comme ça
s'est produit ces dernières semaines est
bien de les menacer de sanctions ou de
licenciement par ailleurs l'économie
biélorusse est très dépendante de la
russie
80% de son énergie vient de la russie et
pour son commerce extérieur elle dépend
à 60% de la russie donc tout ça montre
que en un quart de siècle dans le fond
c'est un peu un échec de la gestion
économique de monsieur loukachenko et
peut-être que ceux ci d'ailleurs suffi à
le discréditer
alors la réforme constitutionnelle
évoqué est promise par alexandre
loukachenko pour sortir de la crise
d'ailleurs le kremlin a confirmé cette
promesse du président biélorusse est ce
qu'elle est plus que nécessaire selon
vue il peut changer les choses alors
lire poutine a raison il a pris
loukachenko au mot loukachenko a
prononcé le mot référendum devant les
ouvriers de l'usiné de tracteurs à minsk
et il a dit mais je peut réformer la
constitution
avoir une nouvelle répartition des
pouvoirs faire un référendum et ensuite
de nouvelles élections
et puis après il a eu l'air de se
rétracter un petit peu il ya un petit
peu peur de sa propre audace mais il l'a
dit et vladimir poutine le prend au mot
ce qui signifie que ils pensent que en
effet il
mieux de réformer la constitution aux
biélorusses alors maintenant comment
faire évidemment qui mettre autour de la
table pour préparer un nouveau texte de
constitution
est ce que monsieur loukachenko
acceptera de faire venir des
représentants de l'opposition politique
des gens qui manifestent dans la rue
depuis son élection
des gens qui sont en exil ou des gens
qui sont en prison pour discuter du
nouveau projet de constitution s'il le
rédige tout seul évidemment ça ne
résoudra pas le problème politique alors
il ya des experts dans beaucoup de pays
des experts russes des experts dans les
pays de l'union européenne des experts
dans les organisations internationales
qui peuvent l'aider à rédiger cette
constitution alors quelles peuvent être
les acteurs pour sortir de la crise
alors bien sûr la russie est un acteur
majeur et la russie a intérêt à ce que
ce qui se passe en biélorussie se calme
donc pour le moment
elle demande à monsieur lucas de chaque
coup de faire le nécessaire
elle lui fait confiance compte tenu de
son expérience politique encore une fois
mais il n'est pas certain que si le
désordre continuer si monsieur le cas de
chèques ou s'avérait impossible de
résoudre la crise que moscou reste les
bras ballants devant cette situation
alors il ya plusieurs solutions est en
effet moscou pas cherché à intervenir
par la voie juridique ou par d'autres
moyens
évidemment la russie et la biélorussie
font partie comme ça été dit dans leur
conférence de presse de l'organisation
du traité de sécurité de coopération qui
regroupe aussi quatre autres pays d'asie
centrale
et cette organisation qui date de 2002 a
pour objet de veiller à la sécurité des
uns et les autres par conséquent on voit
bien que monsieur loukachenko a envie de
faire appel à cette organisation du
traité de sécurité de coopération qui
réunit six pays de l'ancienne union
soviétique
on pourrait aussi penser à
l'organisation de sécurité de
coopération européenne dont la russie et
la biélorussie font également partie
comme
pratiquement tous les pays d'europe est
loin c'est d'ailleurs proposé ses bons
offices
mais monsieur loukachenko dont
l'objectif principal semble être de
garder le pouvoir contre vents et marées
n'a pas envie de voir ces acteurs
extérieurs intervenir alors peut-être
une dernière remarque après tout la
biélorussie n'est le seul pays européen
qui ne soit pas membre du conseil de
l'europe
c'est un peu une bizarrerie mais la
biélorussie avait posé sa candidature en
1993 et puis monsieur loukachenko est
arrivé au pouvoir en 1994 il n'a plus
montré aucun intérêt pour cette
organisation dont la russie fait partie
et dont tous les pays d'europe
à l'est comme à l'ouest font partie donc
peut-être qu'un jour il aura envie de
rejoindre le conseil de l'europe
merci beaucoup au club blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse
nouveau rebondissement dans l affaire
avec ces navalni des laboratoires
français et suédois aurait confirmé son
empoisonnement selon berlin il avance la
présence de nos vies de choc selon le
porte parole du gouvernement allemand
de son côté moscou déplorant n'avoir
toujours pas reçu d'éléments de preuve
de l'allemagne aujourd'hui veille mire
poutine et emmanuel macron tu eu une
conversation téléphonique sur cette
affaire on en parle avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
oui les présidents russe et français se
sont rués au téléphone sur initiative de
la partie russe s'est à cette occasion
qu emmanuel macron a demandé à la russie
une clarification sur je cite la
tentative d'assassinât l'empoisonnement
d'alexei navalni regarder une
clarification est nécessaire de la part
de la russie dans le cadre d'une enquête
crédible et transparente
la france partage sur la base de ses
propres analyses des conclusions de
plusieurs de ses partenaires européens
sur les faits d'empoisonnement à l'aide
d'un agents neurotoxiques nos vies
tchèque alexeï navalni qui au passage va
mieux son état de santé s'améliore il
peut même quitté de façon temporaire son
lit d'hôpital et réponse aux
déclarations d' emmanuel macron vladimir
poutine a répondu il a tenu à réitérer
la position de la russie à savoir
comment voulez vous que l'on nous
une enquête nous russe si l'allemagne
refuse de nous communiquer les les
données que nous lui demandons afin de
pouvoir justement enquêter je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait du
communiqué du kremlin vladimir poutine a
souligné que les accusations non fondées
contre la partie russe était
inappropriée dans le contexte actuel il
a souligné que pour connaître les
circonstances réelles de l'incident un
transfert des biomatériaux par des
spécialistes allemands en russie
accompagnés d'une conclusion officielle
fondée sur les résultats des analyses
prélever alexeï navalni ainsi que la
mise en oeuvre d'un travail conjoint
avec des médecins russes étaient
nécessaires alors bien sûr les deux
parties ont promis de faire des efforts
de coopérer davantage sur ce dossier
mais si la situation en reste là un
entendre de nombreux responsables
occidentaux à l'heure moscou
s'exposerait à de nouvelles sanctions de
la part à la fois de l'union européenne
ou encore des états unis reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
coronavirus la communication du
gouvernement sur cette crise certains
chercheurs universitaires ou encore
médecins la trouve trop anxiogène et
puis norme et non sur la communication
cette fois du ministre de l'intérieur
dans sa lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
gérald darmanin multiplie les sorties et
les vocables sur ce thème
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire france 3 c'est un
cycle de polichinelle je ne pourrais pas
qu'il appartient à la france dé l'eau
des problèmes entre ivoiriens le
président ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'imprimer leurs produits il faut
demander au régime ivoiris déférents
sorte d n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions la tension est né à toulouse
vous demandait un report du scrutin
prévu le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les ciconstances paris c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la frontale de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refera met à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais là d'une
décision invraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons terme la stratégie de
conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
grâce à ce type de pratiques il existe
sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni mourad la faim
justifie les prix
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature a dû pdc y votre parti reste
crédible partir du moment où le
prisonnier colombier revire la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement après
allemand parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
[Musique]
rodolphe gombergh vous avez découvert
que l'imagerie médicale qui était le
coeur de votre métier avait une
dimension artistique me suis aperçu que
c'était l'art qui faisait avancer la
science et la science qui faisait la
banque c'est là l'image est belle mais
mais en général le mal qu'elle révèle il
est terrifiant au moment du coc vite
quand j'ai attrapé bois même la maladie
je me suis dit mais pourquoi j'utilise
pas ma technique de droite et de virton
life a pour mot thorax propres et pour
le virus j'ai pu suivre son évolution
comme henry ça s'aggravait ou au
contraire comment ça s'est battu mais
quand on a découvert le colis dansait on
sait comment ils et comment
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal
les mèches du mal
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission 21h
heure de paris tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 14
septembre la rentrée sociale en france
de nombreuses mobilisations sont prévues
ce mois-ci comme celle de la sncf le 17
septembre
les gilets jaunes eux étaient de nouveau
dans la rue samedi dernier l'occasion de
se demander si leur popularité s'est
effondrée
oui à en croire certains titres de
presse non si l'on s'en tient aux
résultats d'un sondage à une guerre
antidrogue le ministre de l'intérieur
entend bien la mener si une amende
forfaitaire pour les consommateurs de
cannabis a été généralisés à tout le
territoire depuis le 1er septembre
gérald darmanin multiplie également les
sorties sur le sujet tout comme certains
vocable de stupéfiants le ministre de
l'intérieur est-il encore audible nous
en parlerons avec nos invités
ils ont un appel à emmanuel macron 76
parlementaires se sont joints à l'appel
de familles pour le rapatriement
d'enfants français retenu en syrie la
tribune a été publiée dans le parisien
et un rassemblement était prévu ce week
end
la question du retour elle divise
toujours autant
qualifiée d'historique par donald trump
l'israël signera demain un accord celui
de la normalisation de ses relations
avec les émirats arabes unis mais aussi
avec bahreïn une signature qui aura un
impact symbolique fort pour l'état
hébreu mais aussi pour d'autres pays du
moyen-orient
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france et les
derniers chiffres 6158 nouveau 4
qu'ovide confirmé par un test 39
nouveaux foyers recensés dans les
dernières 24 heures
on compte également 34 décès en milieu
hospitalier
pour en parler nous sommes avec philippe
laurent médecins généralistes bonsoir
philippe laurent merci d'être avec nous
alors vous êtes signataires d'une
tribune publiée dans mediapart
nous voulons plus être gouvernés par la
peur 35 chercheurs universitaires et
médecins dont vous critiquent la
communication du gouvernement sur la
crise du coc vite qu'il juge trop
anxiogène pour quelles raisons
expliquées nous bien alors moi j'ai été
interpellé par cette tribune parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un problème tant
que médecin généraliste auxquelles je
suis confronté tous les jours c'est les
angoisses des patients et c'est
réellement un problème difficile parce
qu'on sent que les gens sont extrêmement
touchées extrêmement anxieux on n'a pas
une consultation sans qu'on soit amené à
être amené à traiter ce sujet et on sent
vraiment une des gens désemparés
une communication qui donne l'impression
de ne pas trop savoir où on va et donc
on a vraiment l'impression que les
patients sont complètement dans le dos
tu met un petit peu en en question tout
ce qu'on peut leur raconter vu toutes
les différentes propositions qui sont
faites donc c'est vrai que c'est pour
moi quelque chose d'extrêmement
difficile
quelque chose de quotidien que
j'affronte tous les jours donc c'est
vrai quand j'ai vu cette tribune j'ai
trouvé que ça faisait un grand écho et
ça fait beaucoup de sens donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai signé
j'ai signé cette tribune voilà vous vous
dites voilà on entend bien le l'anxiété
des patients que vous décrivez mais ce
que c'est vraiment la foi du
gouvernement je fais l'avocat du diable
c'est la communication du gouvernement
qui est trop anxiogène
on s'est tout simplement le virus
lui-même je ne ferai pas de raccourci
comme celui que vous faites jeu en
disant que c'est la faute du
gouvernement
je dirais que c'est la question je n'en
fais pas une question
y'a juste pas que c'est la faute de la
communication générale actuelle qui est
extrêmement anxiogènes donc la
communication donc par d'ocz parler donc
le gouvernement c'est une chose mais la
cool de la communication par un certain
nombre de médias c'est vrai que ça
entretient une anxiété ça entretient un
stress et en fait on n'est plus dans un
sentiment de peur et ce sentiment de
peur je pense est extrêmement délétère
pour pour pouvoir réagir plus
favorablement plus positivement pour
essayer d'avoir une prise de conscience
meilleure par rapport à ce qu'il faut
faire pour pouvoir affronter ce virus
parce que je vais pas remettre en doute
et en question en effet le fait qu'on a
des taux qui augmente donc vous avez lu
sur marseille le préfet a dit qu'il y
avait des des taux à 10 6 2 fin de
positivité nous ici sur la région dans
le var en à des taux donc puisqu'on a
des études qui sont fait tacler
laboratoire avec lesquels on travaille
donc où nous sommes
localement nous à des chiffres qui ont
de 3 8 à 5 2% de tests positifs donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya une augmentation des
positive pitt et mais des tests positifs
les malades vous avez évoqué le dernier
chiffre de santé flanc depuis de données
par santé publique france ce soir donc
plus plus quatre 148 cas réels sur les
sardines ces sept derniers jours ce qui
t'a liseret en réa et une 34 morts dont
24 heures donc c'est sûr que tout ça on
peut pas le mettre en question moi ce
qui m'interroge c'est pourquoi cette
peur entretenue pourquoi toute cette
anxiété entretenu et c'est plus là où je
me pose des questions en tant que
médecin et n'entend qu'eux aussi citoyen
justement tant que médecin c'est très
important ce que l'on ne dit pas ce que
vous touchez au coeur d'un problème vous
venez nous dire voilà je ne nie pas les
chiffres mais sont-ils si importants que
ça d'un point de vue du médecin on va
pas voilà reparler des chiffres du
cancer des morts sur la route et cetera
et cetera
est ce qu'aujourd'hui cette peur selon
vous est ce qu'elle est quand même en
corrélation avec une situation réelle ou
pas tellement finalement une situation
réelle de pandémie enfin d'évolution et
de circulation du virus
ça c'était une réalité simplement c'est
le mode de communes
question il ya trois mois on vous
annonçait des chiffres de morts et de
patience totalisant réanimation
aujourd'hui on nous annonce et qui fait
surtout écho qui résonne sont le chiffre
de cas positifs donc tous les jours on
nous annonce aujourd'hui par exemple
7158 cas positifs en plus donc en fait
les cas positifs ça veut dire ça veut
pas forcément dire des gens malades
enfin moi dans mon exercice quotidien
qui certainement pas significatif mais
bon qui est mien je vois j'ai vu des cas
positifs sur en particulier chez des
sujets jeunes qui vont qui vont plutôt
bien qu'ils sont peu très peu
symptomatiques
donc il faut je pense aussi garder un
peu sa raison garder et puis voir un
petit peu ce qui sera intéressant c'est
de savoir sur ces cas positifs en fait
tu es l'état clinique des patients et
c'est ça qui est important que pouvoir
avoir une idée et puis c'est surtout
voir le nombre de morts est quand même
assez significatif on est à 34 morts
donc aujourd'hui donc c'est il n'y a pas
d'explosion comme on avait à l'époque
deux à l'époque mars avril
alors bien sûr c'est qu'elle touche
aussi qui est extrêmement fluctuants qui
quasiment évolue de jour en jour donc
c'est vrai que notre attitude doit
s'adapter à toutes les tout ce qu'on
peut constater mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi garder un petit peu de raison un
petit peu de sang froid par rapport à
tout ça donc moi je vois des gens qui me
disent ne plus sortir de tout chez eux
tellement ils sont angoissés et stressé
des gens qui sont vraiment cloîtrés chez
eux dans le traumatisme docteur de
justement ce qui s'est passé il ya cinq
mois
ces images difficiles la télévision les
hôpitaux surchargés ce qui s'est passé
dans le grand est est ce qu'on n'est pas
finalement dans le traumatisme de sly on
veut à tout prix éviter aussi et un
recond finement jeu
j'entends bien je comprends mais est ce
que la peur est le meilleur conseiller
pour ça parce que la peur est la
meilleure façon pour conserver une
conscience sur la nécessité des gestes
barrières sur le jeu je m'interroge
est-ce que c'est la peur qui va nous
permettre de réaliser
au mieux ou est ce que c'est la peur qui
peut au contraire vous amener à des
réactions plus de qui vante faut
regarder ce qui se passe avec les pros
masquer les antilles masque on est dans
une société qui est déjà fragile qui est
en train de se priver par rapport à ces
questions donc ça s'interroge beaucoup
sur nos comportements sur comment ont
réagi par rapport à cette situation qui
est difficile
donc selon moi je le pose beaucoup de
questions même si j'ai mal en terre
pardonnez moi de vous vous coupez mais
mais on sait dans la lignée de ce qu'on
se pose comme question ce nouveau clip à
la télévision quand on voit la jeune
embrasser sa grand-mère qui convoie à la
fin se retrouver en réanimation ça
rappelle un petit peu les images de la
sécurité routière on imagine que d'après
ce que vous nous dites vous voilà vous
n'est pas en accord avec ce genre de
communication en accord avec ce genre de
communication qui est quand même quelque
chose de
c'est déjà la situation est assez
compliqué les gens je pense sont assez
stressés
je pense que dans les effets collatéraux
de cette de cet épisode sanitaire il y
aura tous les problèmes de gestion du
stress les problèmes de jeu pense que
c'est une réalité il n'a pas encore
toutes les conséquences et c'est vrai
que ce clip
bon je pense qu'il faut éveiller les
consciences à la nécessité des gestes
barrière se laver les mains de fin de
garde et la distanciation social ça
c'est fondamental ça c'est ça peut pas
se remettre en question mais de là à
envoyer des images aussi enfin violente
parce que moi j'ai trouvé ça que l'on
sait non je sais quelque chose qui
rajoute à la peur et à l' angoisse
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
leroy je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste d'avoir été avec nos
directions rt france la popularité des
gilet jaune à nouveau dans la rue
s'effondrerait tel selon quelques titres
de presse seuls 10% des français
soutiendrait actuellement le mouvement
en réalité de sondages dont il se
réclame semble dire linverse les
explications de katia technique
les français en ont ils assez de gilets
jaunes en croire une certaine presse la
réponse est oui
s'appuyant sur un sondage ifop le
quotidien le parisien ne craint pas
d'affirmer sur twitter le 2 septembre
que seuls 10% des français d
encore soutenir les gilets jaunes dans
l'article mentionnait expliquant que le
mouvement s'essouffle on apprend un
scoop
une étude ifop que nous dévoilons en
exclusivité ribel que seul un français
sur dix se sent proche du mouvement
un constat bien fâcheux pour le retour
des contestataires du pouvoir dans la
rue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le sondage en question n'est que
mentionné dans l'article en ligne et
n'est pas accessible
aussitôt bfm leur emboîtent le pas voilà
ce qu'affirme l'article d'après l'étude
seuls 10% de la population âgée de 18
ans et plus se sentir proche des gilet
jaune soit entre 4 et 4,5 millions de
personnes
l'adresse du lien elle ne laisse aucune
place au doute alors les gilet jaune
serait t'il isolé mal aimé fermez le ban
étonnant pour un mouvement encore
soutenue en mai dernier par 53% des
français
toujours selon l'ifop alors comment
expliquer ce désamour les français
aurait-il attrapé le virus du
néolibéralisme durant l'été
[Applaudissements]
aurait-il changé de couleur préférée et
bien non et pour comprendre ces titres
il suffit de se livrer à la lecture
objective d'un sondage pourtant très
claire les journalistes du service
tchèque news de libération ont donc
jouer au chevalier blanc en examinant
les termes et les chiffres de l' enquête
le sondage avait posé la question diriez
vous que vous êtes un gilet jaune les
femmes 10 % sont en réalité les
interroger qui avait dit se sentir gilet
jaune mais oh
que voit-on 41% de plus ont déclaré
soutenir le mouvement
la calculatrice est formel 10 + 41
cela fait cinquante et un pour cent de
soutien des gilet jaune ce qui veut dire
que seuls 49% ne les soutiennent pas
sondages à l'appui une courte majorité
est donc toujours favorable gilet jaune
apparemment l'école en visio semble déjà
avoir laissé pas mal de séquelles en
maths et cette nouvelle bévue ne va pas
arranger les rapports entre les jets les
jaunes et les médias traditionnels
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin s'est une nouvelle fois exprimé
chez nos confrères de lci sur la
légalisation du cannabis en france
il s'y oppose fermement et assure que la
lutte contre la prise de stupéfiants et
l'une de ses priorités
l'occasion de faire le point en images
sur les chiffres de la consommation de
drogues en france
en france la consommation de stupéfiants
s'est nettement accélérée au cours de la
dernière décennie
[Rires]
en tête le cannabis qui représentent
plus de 80% de la consommation de
stupéfiants dans l'hexagone
avec 3,9 millions de consommateurs dont
1,2 million sur une base régulière
le cannabis touche essentiellement les
jeunes et plus particulièrement les
garçons à 16 ans les jeunes français
sont actuellement les premiers
consommateurs de rang
en france on dénombre environ cent
cinquante mille consommateurs de cocaïne
à ce jour une consommation qui touche là
aussi une population jeune en 2008 3,3
pour cent des jeunes de 17 ans avait
déjà expérimenté la cocaïne
[Musique]
la consommation d'ecstasy et des
nouvelles drogues de synthèse est devenu
plus fréquentes notamment dans le monde
de la nuit
la consommation d'héroïne elle semble
s'être stabilisée ces dernières années
cette drogue concernait déjà trois cent
soixante mille personnes en 2005
[Musique]
c'est dans ce contexte que gérald
darmanin fait de la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants
une bataille idéologique et le ministre
de l'intérieur ne mâche pas ses mots
la drogue c'est de là on ne va pas
légalisée 7
des propos qui ne laisse que peu de
place à une légalisation du cannabis
comme le demandent certains spécialistes
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
et c'est donc une guerre antidrogue que
le ministre de l'intérieur entend mener
outre les actions sur le terrain
réalisée par les forces de l'ordre
gérald darmanin multiplie les sorties et
mène la bataille de la communication
alors est-il encore audible non faîtier
pas trop sur ce thème est pour en parler
nous sommes avec arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire bonsoir arnaud
benedetti merci d'être avec nous m'ont
soir à vos côtés et lexandre langlois
secrétaire général du syndicat policier
vigie bonsoir avons également alexandre
langlois alors avant de vous donner la
parole messieurs je voudrais qu'on
écoute les déclarations de gérald
darmanin ce matin et surtout le
vocabulaire employé par le ministre de
l'intérieur nous augmentons le prix du
tabac dans ce gouvernement
on ne va pas légaliser la drogue à côté
on ne va pas dire que le tabac c'est
bien et légaliser la drogue ce qu'il
faut extrêmement souligné c'est qu'il ya
tous les jours des associations des
parents des policiers et des élus locaux
qui luttent contre cet art la drogue
ces deux là je le dis avec les mots de
tous les parents que j'ai reçu dans ma
permanence d'élue alors la parole entre
d'abord un spécialiste de la
communication pour commencer parce
qu'évidemment on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude d'entendre ce genre de deux
mots dans la bouche du patron de la
place beauvau il imprime son stylo
benedetti gérald darmanin
on a beaucoup dit que j'ai un barman et
était une réplique
quelques années plus tard de nicolas
sarkozy qui lui aussi avait été une
usager de parler cash
et vous quand il dénoncé les racailles
qui le promettait de l'est de les
nettoyer au rokkasho au karcher donc on
est là disons dont une dans une ligne
politique qui vise finalement à bordés à
droite
si vous voulez gérald darmanin c
l'homme qui est là pour dans la macro ni
actuellement montrer que l'on entend un
certain nombre de préoccupations des
électrices et des électeurs de droite
donc il est ce flotteur de droite de
cette majorité qui vise à évoquer la
figure qui pour certains est une figure
nostalgique pour certains militants et
parfois sur certains électeurs et
électrices de la droite républicaine de
nicolas sarkozy donc il est dans ce rôle
c'est un choix de communication alors
vous le policier alexandre langlois
quand vous entendez votre ministre
parler sur ce ton vous vous dites ça y
est on est on est sauvé quelqu'un a
décidé de prendre en main de problème je
crois que les mots étaient bien dit par
volonté l'intervenant qu'avec moi c'est
un choix de communication nous sommes
dans la communication
on pense qu'on a déjà vécu ça avec
monsieur sarkozy qu'elle a été doublé
avec la politique du chiffre et pour le
moment on a eu beaucoup de
gesticulations on a eu beaucoup de
choses et là en plus nous avons une
copie de monsieur sarkozy s'ingère de la
copie est toujours moins bien que
l'original donc même pour les
ostalgiques ce sera pas du tout pareil
donc pour le moment on a beaucoup de
gesticulations l'année dernière monsieur
castaner avait inauguré l'eau fasse un
nouvel office pour lutter contre la
drogue et en rassemblant plusieurs
services ils avaient dit qu'il y aurait
plus de monde dans le service et comme
il avait pris des des douaniers des
gendarmes et de différentes unités
finalement au final il y avait moins de
monde qu'à l'origine donc en mutualisant
les moyens donc pour le moment on n'est
pas bien sûr que ça va changer grand
chose au final
alors question communication on peut se
poser la question à nos bd et y est ce
que finalement le style darmanin ça
marche
à qui parle-t-il précisément aux
policiers on voit pas tous les policiers
en tout cas on français il parle bien
évidemment d'abord aux françaises et aux
français
ceci dit le premier front qui était
celui de gérald darmanin quand il est
arrivé le plat c'était d'essayer de
mais concilier le ministre de
l'intérieur avec un corps social la
police qui considérait que dans les
toutes dernières séquences notamment
après le déconfinement elle avait été
maltraitée par son ministre donc le
premier objectif c'était 7
j'allais dire cette première ligne de
front ensuite il ya eu tout un contexte
durant l'été d'événements qui ont
particulièrement marqué l'actualité où
on a vu progressivement l'enjeu
sécuritaire qui avait un peu disparu du
fait du du conflent réapparaître dans
l'agenda politique donc on a un ministre
de l'intérieur qui au regard de cet
enjeu veut montrer qu'il occupe le poste
qu'ils entretiennent discours à la fois
d'autorité et de fermeté pour tout
simplement défendre l'ordre public
si toutes ses formes alors elle est sans
l'ombre là on a compris que vous adhérez
pas nécessairement à ce style darmanin
vous parliez de son hyper communication
en fait voilà son style proche de
sarkozy mais voilà peut-être en moins
bien si je prend vos mots vous disiez
tout de même que ça imprime chez
certains policiers
c'est un petit peu mieux que le stylo
castaner au moins pire si j'ose dire
pour vous dire qu'on avait touché le
fond avec monsieur k ster on peut que
remonter
je rappelle que monsieur castaner les
policiers lui en veulent beaucoup pour
sa gestion des masques et qui nous avait
soufflé pour le colis de ces
gesticulations diverses et variées et le
soupçon avéré qui a été vraiment pas
passé donc effectivement on pouvait
difficilement faire pire que monsieur
castaner monsieur da manha par contre
gesticule beaucoup fait beaucoup de
communication mais au final qu'est ce
qui va se passer dans la réalité les
policiers ne sont pas multiplier comme
des petits pains les policiers sont
utilisés qu'on a pu voir en course ce
week-end contre des manifestations les
encadre très lourdement par rapport au
nombre de manifestants dire que ça
pendant ce temps là ils ne sont pas
ailleurs à lutter contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
la deuxième chose également c'est qu'on
nous demande de lutter pour faire du
chiffre
parce que la politique du chiffre dans
la police nationale n'a pas changé et
même on s'attend que ça va s'amplifier
vu qu'ils veulent publie les chiffres
mensuellement
on va nous demander de faire du chiffre
pour la lutte contre la drogue et qui ce
qu'on veut comme on fait du chiffre
en dressant des contraventions par
exemple pour les consommateurs de
cannabis
pendant ce temps là on ne s'occupe pas
des trafics les policiers sont
demandeurs de démanteler les trafics y
sont pas demandeurs de s'occuper des
boulette de shit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
pensé révolutionner le pays en faisant
ça ou assurer la sécurité de tout le
monde
ils auront fait des chiffres ils ont
rassuré la coque du gouvernement mais
c'est pas comme ça que les gens vont
vivre sérieusement hockey des policiers
qui savent on a des collègues qui savent
où sont les cages des fois et cetera ils
n'ont pas forcément le droit
d'intervenir lors du bal trafic était
l'endroit où on se sent impuissant et
c'est un puissance qu'est révoltante
alors qu'on nous dise finalement fait de
casser les os conservateur le
consommateur passe pour une
contravention très bien encore faut-il
qu'ils soient solvables mais ce n'est
pas ça le coeur du métier pourquoi les
policiers seront très on n'est pas
rentré pour faire des auxiliaires des
impôts on est rentré pour mettre les
délinquants et les criminels en prison
arnaud bénéfices importants ce qui nous
dit alexandre l'envoi parce qu'en gros
il nous dit voilà il ya de la
communication d'un côté et puis dans le
fond on sait où sont les trafics mais en
gros on n'a pas le droit d'intervenir il
ya une vraie hypocrisie en double
langage de la part du gouvernement
vous savez c'est une des grandes figures
classiques de la critique de la
communication si la communication n'est
pas suivi d'actes et de moyens associés
à ces actes elle reste forcément de la
communication et c'est bien aujourd'hui
en tout cas une partie des critiques qui
commencent à émerger contre l'action ou
en tout cas la non action où l'action
seulement communicante du ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est vrai que il a relevé le niveau
sémantique mais il ne suffit pas de
relever le niveau sémantique
si encore une fois vous ne venez pas des
politiques publiques qui sont conformes
aux mots que vous prononcez et ben vous
êtes malheureusement vraisemblablement
en mesure de décevoir un assez
rapidement et c'est à ce défi
aujourd'hui qui est confronté un gérald
darmanin qui en plus à un président de
la république qui sur la question
régaliennes a toujours été soupçonnée de
de maîtriser a suffisamment cette
question là d'ailleurs même au moment de
l'élection présidentielle ont crédité
d'une compétence économique world une
volonté réformatrice
emmanuel macron mais on avait des doutes
sur sa capacité en tout cas à 10 ont
mené des politiques régaliennes qui soit
efficace
je vous renvoie justement d'écouter
notre petite réplique un prononcé par
gérald darmanin ce matin quand l'enfant
de 14 ans touche plus en une journée que
son père qui travaille à l'usiné d'à
côté on ne peut pas s'étonner qu'il y
ait une crise d'autorité
alors c'est une petite phrase comme ça
mais alexandre l'envoi il ya quand même
du vrai ce que vous pouvez imaginer
quand même une forme de sincérité en
tout cas dans l'eau dans la volonté et
votre ministre de l'intérieur ça peut
faire changer les esprits quand même bon
on peut l'espérer en tous les cas après
de la sincérité peut-être pas forcément
en tous les cas une non ces propos là
les derniers c'est assez lucide et c'est
a décidé également c'est qu'on peut
constater qu'il ya deux choses il ya
ceux qui vont tomber par choix dans
la voie de la délinquance parce
qu'effectivement ça paye bien ça
rapporte beaucoup plus donc voila mais
après qu'est ce que font les pouvoirs
publics pour mettre fin à ces personnes
parce qu on est bien d'accord qu'en
s'attaquant aux consommateurs et ne
s'occupe pas de ce qu'ils rapportent de
l'argent derrière la deuxième chose
également c'est que mais aussi un taux
de chômage qui est parallèle dans c dans
certaines dans certains quartiers
difficiles où cité populaire et qui fait
que les pays bas qui subissent pas faut
bien que j'arrive à survivre à tel point
qu'on a vu des collègues qui avaient
démantelé un trafic de stups c'était
sous le quinquennat de monsieur hollande
dans une cité et le mois suivant là on
leur avait fait des pays citation ce à
des prix plus ou moins de travailler ou
le mois suivant leur a dit oui mais plus
personne peut payer son loyer hlm donc
arrêter de démanteler des trafics et je
rappelle qu'en plus ce pour le pib de la
france mettant le trafic de drogue et
dans le pib de la france donc en plus il
arrive de sueur économique qui est
intégré donc à toute cette hypocrisie ce
double discours où on nous dit faites
les choses et ne fait pas à côté de ça
et après pour revenir sur le modèle
également une autre anecdote police sur
la politique des statistiques et du
chiffre on avait dans un commissariat de
brigades une brigade qui s'occupait de
la tranquillité publique qui
interpellait des gens qui étaient nocifs
parce que les gens les appeler pour des
agressions et des choses assez grave
tous les cas qui était pénible pour les
habitants et à côté de ça avait une
autre équipe qui faisait 90 boulette de
shit par mois malheureusement à cause
d'une réduction d'effectifs qui avait eu
du tout monsieur sarkozy une des deux
brigades a fermé on n'a gardé que celle
qu'avaient les meilleures statistiques
sans regarder le contenu donc comme
monsieur de la maladie qu'il allait
publier les chiffres mensuellement la
peur qui essaient de course aux chiffres
cette course à la production statistique
et que personne à y regarder ce qu'il ya
dedans alors que malheureusement et des
rapports parlementaires qui montre que
c'est un peu le truc à chaque fois pour
faire dire ce qu'on veut à ces chiffres
arnaud vélizy le mot de la fin pour vous
cette politique du chiffre et
effectivement on en revient toujours à
lui
ça rappelle un certain nicolas sarkozy
oui mais si vous voulez il ya la
politique du chiffre il y allait donner
j'allais dire statistiques et puis il ya
la réalité le telle qu'elle est vécue et
ressentie alors parfois de manière
subjective mais aussi parfois de manière
objective à la fois par les policiers
mais aussi par les citoyennes et les
citoyens et donc c'est toute la
difficulté qui consiste d'un côté a
réaffirmé un discours d'autorité dans
lequel finalement une grande majorité de
le concitoyen se retrouveront et ensuite
la déclinaison de s'être de cette
autorité sur le terrain est déclinée
l'autorité sur le terrain ce n'est pas
seulement se limiter à des déclarations
c'est encore une fois donné des moyens
comme le réclament les policiers et
surtout ne pas hésiter à mener des
politiques publiques qui soient des
politiques publiques qui met un terme à
une forme d'appauvrissement de l'état à
la réalité c'est que ce que nous vivons
est d'aller en charente d'ahmad el had
et par ex pour saab directement
c'est une politique d'appauvrissement
des moyens publics de l'état et
notamment des moyens régalien la justice
c'est exactement dans la même situation
voire pire que celle de la police en
l'occurrence et cette politique est
menée depuis très nombreuses années
quelles que soient les majorités et
c'est ce que aujourd'hui renvoie comme
critique tout un ensemble de
fonctionnaires qui sont confrontés à la
réalité du terrain qui doivent traiter
et aussi à la réalité des moyens qui
manquent pour finalement d'une certaine
manière remplir les objectifs que leur
fixe le gouvernement quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup en eau benedetti et
alexandre langlois d'avoir été avec nous
dans quelques instants
elle nous parlerons du rapatriement
d'enfants français retenu en syrie
réclamée par des familles et des
parlementaires et puis vous évoqueront
l'accord entre israël et les émirats
arabes unis mais aussi avec le bahreïn
une nouvelle percée diplomatique et
rebat les cartes au moyen-orient
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire france 3 c'est un
cycle de polichinelle je ne pourrais pas
qu'il appartient à la france dé l'eau
des problèmes entre ivoiriens le
président ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'imprimer leurs produits il faut
demander au régime ivoiris déférents
sorte d n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions l'attention à toulouse vous
demandé un report des scrutins prévus le
31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les ciconstances paris c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
catholique et féministe facilement il y
à un discrédit de principes posés sur le
mot féministe alors que c'est simplement
la reconnaissance de son existence
d'être faits mineurs est ce que vous
diriez qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an tu
reçois masculin dans l'église
bien sûr qu'il y à nantes reçoit metz
que la chine est un plafond de verre qui
empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église
elles ne sont jamais autonomes dans leur
dans leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière
donc il est temps il est temps de dire
que l'église ne peut pas fonctionner sur
un seul de ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une scène
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
on pensera à tous bienvenue sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez 21h30
heure française ils ont directement
interpellé
emmanuel macron 76 parlementaires se
sont joints à l'appel de familles pour
leur rapatriement d'enfants français
retenu en syrie la tribune a été publiée
dans le parisien et un rassemblement
était prévu ce week end alors la
question est elle toujours aussi
clivante
réponse avec christine fages vos petits
enfants ont fait leur rentrée des
classes la semaine dernière les nôtres
n'ont jamais vu d'école où se
souviennent à peine de leur maîtresse
c'est par ces mots que débute la lettre
du collectif des familles unies adressée
à emmanuel macron est publié dans le
parisien en appel soutenu par 76
parlementaires dont des eurodéputés tous
réclament le rapatriement des enfants
français retenus dans des camps syrien
auprès de leur mère jihadistes je suis
l'une des soixante seize élus demandant
le retour des enfants de nationalité
française victime de traitements
inhumains ainsi que de leur mère retenus
dans des camps en syrie il s'agit là
d'un impératif humanitaire et
sécuritaire
j'ai signé cette tribune de trop
nombreux enfants français croupissent
encore dans ces camps en syrie ne pas
les rapatriés n'est pas digne de la
france
la politique du cas par cas n'a plus de
sens
nous sommes de plus en plus de
parlementaires à soutenir le
rapatriement des enfants de syrie nous
ne pouvons pas détourner le regard
la france a une responsabilité
particulière et doit l'assumer
j'ai signé cet appel avec 76
parlementaires pour que la france
rapatriés immédiatement les enfants
français victimes de traitements
inhumains et dégradants qui périssent
dans les camps syriens et leur mère
selon les estimations de l'unicef près
de 29000 enfants étrangers serait à son
jour retenu en syrie parmi eux près de
200 seraient français selon le collectif
des familles unies la plupart pourraient
être détenus dans les camps de réfugiés
d'al hall situé au nord-est du pays dans
des conditions humanitaires déplorable
les conditions sanitaires dans
lesquelles survivent ces enfants sont
parfaitement indigne
plus de 300 enfants sont décédés dans le
sol quand dallol en
2019 et des dizaines d'enfants sont
morts de malnutrition de déshydratation
d'arrêt cardiaque et d'hémorragies
internes depuis le début de l'été au nom
de l'impératif humanitaire nous
parlementaires appelons la france à
rapatrier immédiatement les enfants
français victimes de traitements
inhumains et dégradants qui périssent
dans les camps syrien en finir avec la
politique du cas par cas prônée par
l'état français c'est ce que réclament
ces élus et le collectif des familles
unies depuis le printemps deux nuls 19
28 enfants ont été rapatriés dans
l'hexagone
outre le volet humanitaire les
signataires de cette lettre évoque
l'aspect sécuritaire selon eux les mères
des enfants doivent elles aussi être
rapatriés les évasions sont monnaie
courante dans ces camps et ces femmes
restent à la merci de dèche
les rapatriés permettrait à la justice
française de les juger et de les
condamner
depuis des mois des chapelles
publiquement ses partisans à libérer ces
femmes pour mieux les enrôler et faire
grossir ses rangs les camps de roms et
dallol sont des foyers de violence et de
radicalisation extrêmement dangereux et
l'instabilité de cette zone nous oblige
à rapatrier la centaine de femmes
françaises qui sont détenus pour le
moment le gouvernement ne semble pas
avoir changé de cap sur la question la
classe politique à l'ossif peinent à se
mettre d'accord et 7 à droite de
l'échiquier que se trouvent les opinions
défavorables au rapatriement des enfants
et de leur mère non retour des
djihadistes organisé par macron
aujourd'hui encore trois jihadistes et
leurs neuf enfants ont été rapatriés de
turquie ces individus ont fait le choix
de prendre les armes contre la france
qu'ils soient donc jugé en irak ou en
syrie peut-on vraiment rapatrier des
enfants de djihadistes de 16 ans utilisé
comme arme de guerre par l'état
islamique
l'accueil des enfants doit se faire au
cas par cas rappaz trip sur lci
j'expliquais que pour saisir l'enjeu du
rapatriement des enfants de djihadistes
l'hypothèse de départ doit être que
l'islamisme est un nazisme placé en camp
d'entraînement dès l'âge de 3 ans les
enfants jihadistes sont comme la hitler
jungen des bombes humaines
ludovic rivière avocat au barreau de
toulouse est l'un des signataires de la
tribune selon lui le choix du
gouvernement de ne procéder au cas par
cas serait motivée par un objectif
électoraliste
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a confié à
nos confrères de l'express évoquant je
cite la soumission d'un gouverneur
à l'opinion publique selon un sondage
aux docks sa dance your consulting pour
le figaro et france info paru l'année
dernière
67% des personnes interrogées souhaitent
laisser les enfants de jihadistes en
irak et en syrie
demain israël signera un accord qualifié
d'historique par donald trump celui de
la normalisation de ses relations avec
les émirats arabes unis bahreïn
cette signature aura un impact
symbolique fort pour l'état hébreu mais
aussi pour d'autres pays du moyen-orient
ont fait le point sur les enjeux avec
médecine romagnan et grégoire douce et
d'une pierre deux signatures pour israël
le moyen-orient les émirats arabes unis
et bahreïn s'apprête à conclure un
accord de normalisation de leurs
relations avec l'état hébreu
ces deux états arabes ont un point
commun politique avec tel-aviv leur
animosité envers l'iran mais cette
nouvelle alliance aura tout d'abord une
dimension économique dans une région où
les enjeux liés aux hydrocarbures
tiennent une place importante la
signature se fera sous l'égide des états
unis à la maison blanche une opportunité
politique pour donald trump à la peine
dans les sondages à moins de deux mois
de l'élection présidentielle
bahreïn et israël vont pleinement
normaliser leurs relations diplomatiques
ils vont mettre en place des ambassades
et des ambassadeurs établir des vols
directs entre leurs pays c'est un jour
vraiment history un coup politique aussi
pour benyamin nétanyahou les
manifestations pour la démission du
premier ministre se multiplient depuis
des mois dans le pays
ses détracteurs lui reprochent sa
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus et
son procès pour corruption
l'aboutissement de ces accords est aussi
une manière de reconquérir l'opinion
tout accord de paix est une chose béni
surtout avec un pays musulman ou un pays
arabe
nous savons que pendant longtemps les
pays musulmans n'ont pas reconnu israël
se sont opposés à nous et ont toujours
essayer de nuire à israël par des moyens
diplomatiques ou autre donc chaque
accord de paix conclu avec ces pays dit
qu israël est un pays légitimes y
compris aux yeux du monde musulman
les palestiniens eux vivent ces accords
comme une trahison
al oula ça longtemps hélas les états
unis et israël cherche à établir des
relations avec des pays périphériques
qui n'ont pas de rapport direct avec
l'occupation israélienne afin de
promouvoir l'idée d'une paix régionale
comme alternative à la paix
palestino-israéliennes assalam si
nintendo la wii il y un changement dans
les priorités arabe
ce changement remplace israël comme
menace à la sécurité nationale arabe par
un autre ennemi qui est l'iran et cela
signifie l'abandon des obligations
envers la cause palestinienne
[Musique]
des manifestations sont prévues ce mardi
dans les territoires palestiniens pour
dénoncer ces traités considéré par les
dirigeants comme un coup de poignard
dans le dos jusqu'à présent les deux
seuls pays arabes ayant signé un accord
bilatéral avec israël sont l'egypte et
la jordanie
et pour en parler nous sommes avec david
rigoulet roze chercheur associé à
l'hélice bonsoir david rigoulet roze
merci d'être avec nous d'un enfant qui
parle donc d'un accord historique est ce
que vous partagez cet adjectif
d'historique
oui il ya des éléments de langage de la
part de donald trump s'est pas
surprenant parce que donald trump
considère que c'était un objectif
recherché de durant toute son
administration c'est à dire de favoriser
un rapprochement avéré officiel entre
israël et les pétromonarchies en
l'occurrence dont les émirats en premier
lieu ce qui est fait et de ce point de
vue là effectivement c'est la stratégie
américaine aussi d'isolement l'iran qui
est mise en oeuvre dans à travers ce
rapprochement
donc le président valette rumble va être
présentée comme un succès personnel
notamment dans le cadre de la
perspective d'élections
2 novembre prochain par rapport à ce
noyau dur électoral l'électorat ou
évangélistes justement très pro
israélien et donc ça rentre aussi dans
une logique de politique intérieure mais
au-delà de ça il ya incontestablement un
changement de paradigme au niveau
régional qui aura des conséquences
importantes à moyen et long terme
alors quelles conséquences justement
c'est on peut on peut signaler que
rappeler que c'est le troisième les
émirats appui marraine dernièrement sont
les troisième et quatrième pays arabe à
avoir signé un accord de reconnaissance
hier d'une normalisation avec l'état
hébreu
alors que tu as dit en arabe donc cette
normalisation a été un tabou pendant
longtemps puisque la normalisation était
conditionnée justement par la
reconnaissance des droits palestiniens
et il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui les
enjeux les les enjeux régionaux sont
sont très largement supérieur aux
stricts intérêts palestiniens
en l'occurrence ça justifie d une
convergence objective entre israël et
les pétromonarchies par rapport à la
menace iranienne qui est perçu comme une
menace majeure et donc de ce point de
vue là effectivement c'est un tournant
parce que les pays les deux pays qui
viennent de faire cette normalisation ne
sont pas des pays qui avaient été en
guerre comme comme l'egypte qui a signé
un accord de paix en 79 puis plus tard
justement les la jordanie et en 94
là il se trouve que ce sont des pays pas
directement frontaliers et donc c'est
c'est une brèche dans le boycott à une
cata de justement de d'israël par
rapport à ce qui avait été la ligne
notamment de la ligue arabe
enfin des pays arabes dans leur ensemble
pendant très longtemps donc si on
comprend bien la question palestinienne
n'est plus un obstacle à la
normalisation des relations d'israël
avec le monde arabe
cela prouve ça en tout cas en tout cas
il ya eu incontestablement une
dévaluation stratégique de la cause
palestinienne en tant que tel par
rapport à des enjeux qui
quirky été jugée supérieure y compris
d'ailleurs parlé les défenseurs de cette
cause palestinienne pendant plusieurs
décennies
parce que là là effectivement
l'obsession de la menace iranienne joue
très très largement dans les
rapprochements en question il ya une
logique que sécuritaires stratégiques
régionales pas uniquement d'ailleurs
également économiques et commerciales
mais en tout cas le la variable
stratégique est déterminant dans ce type
de rapprochement mais on sait que les
relations se sont toujours faites plus
ou moins discrètement maintenant il y
aura peut-être moins d'hypocrisie est ce
qu'on n'est pas plus dans le symbole ah
c'est pas un symbole parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas le la
normalisation des que ce soit des
émirats hotbar n était plus ou moins
attendu c'est à dire c'est pas
fondamentalement une surprise il y avait
des contacts depuis plusieurs mois sinon
plusieurs années avec israël des
contacts non non officiels on peut
rappeler qu'en 2018 y avait deux
ministres israéliens qui avaient fait le
voyage justement abou dhabi pour
justement d'aider des cérémonies
officielles de type sportives notamment
et est donc cessé ses contacts son
ancien simplement là il se trouve qu'il
ya une officialisation qui qui prouve
qu'ils avaient le champ dans le
paradigme au niveau régional et qui sera
avec dès qu'il y aura des conséquences
importantes alors le vrai le vrai la
vraie question c'est l'arabie saudite
parce qu'en réalité c'est le prince mbs
qui qui souhaiteraient aussi pouvoir
faire ce rapprochement de manière
officielle mais là il ya dans lequel
l'arabie saudite il ya quand même un
certain nombre de blocages qui pèse et
notamment il ya le historiquement on va
dire le le plan abdallah 2002 qui fait
que l'arabie saoudite n'est pas dans la
tout à fait dans la situation des autres
pays
elle est obligée de faire preuve de
davantage de prudence par rapport aux
effectives ment à ce type de
normalisation merci beaucoup david
rigoulet roze rappelle comme cette
chercheur associé à l'iris spécialiste
du moyen-orient merci d'avoir été avec
nous
un sommet virtuel entre la chine et
l'union européenne a eu lieu aujourd'hui
un sommet à cause du coronavirus mais
l'objectif reste le même
elle malgré les tensions signé un accord
commercial d'ici la fin de l'année aux
accords et aux intérêts multiples pour
la chine comme pour les européens
théo combat avec walid belhani et
clément hospital faire avancer le projet
d'accord sino européen sur le traité
bilatéral d'investissement
c'était l'objectif de ce sommet virtuel
chine une élection le président du
conseil européen
son homologue de la commission la
chancelière allemande et le président
chinois
les européens ont appelé pékin à faire
des concessions pour faciliter l'accès
de son marché aux entreprises du vieux
continent
nous voulons une relation équilibrée
fondée sur le respect pour les intérêts
mutuels
nous considérons que la réciprocité la
transparence doivent être au coeur de
l'engagement porté par l'union
européenne l'êta est multilatérale doit
reposer sur un respect des règles
négocié depuis près de sept ans ces
accords visent à encadrer les
investissements bilatéraux entre l'ue et
la chine
un vaste projet qui comprend la
propriété intellectuelle la fin des
transferts de technologie imposer aux
firmes étrangères en chine ou encore les
subventions aux entreprises publiques
chinoises
mais ces négociations se heurte à des
divergences loin d'être dissipées entre
les deux parties hong kong mer de chine
5 g taïwan où la question des ouigours
sur ce sujet lui a d'ailleurs proposé
l'envoi d'observateurs indépendants dans
la province du zhejiang où pékin est
accusé de persécuter cette minorité
musulmane turcophone
malgré les désaccords persistants la
chine a réaffirmé sa volonté de conclure
un accord avant la fin de l'année
l'après breakes site les négociations
piétinent recul pour certains et pour
cause et députés britanniques ont
examiné aujourd'hui une loi pour revenir
sur l'accord déjà signé entre le royaume
uni
et l'europe le node il plane plus que
jamais sur les négociations ce qui
inquiète évidemment les entreprises
plusieurs organisations de l'industrie
automobile européenne notamment ont
appelé londres et bruxelles à sécuriser
l'accord hélène masquelier l'industrie
automobile lance l'alertent un échec des
négociations sur un accord post
breakbeat entraînerait des pertes
économiques de plus de 100 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans pour la filière
dans la région une vingtaine
d'organisations se sont regroupés pour
demander aux deux parties de parvenir à
un accord de libre-échange satisfaisant
parmi les signataires l'association des
constructeurs européens d'automobiles et
d'autres organisations nationales
françaises allemandes ou britanniques
qui met en garde les économies et les
emplois des deux côtés de la manche sont
sous la menace d'un deuxième coup
dévastateur sous la forme d'une absence
d'accord
l'industrie automobile a déjà endossé
une perte de 100 milliards d'euros en
raison de la crise sanitaire
un odile menacerait fortement le secteur
qui représente près d'un emploi sur 15
faute d'accord sur le breakbeat lieu et
le royaume uni devrait se conformer aux
règles de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce droits de douane élevés et
contrôles aux frontières plus poussée un
scénario qui pénaliserait à la fois
européen et britannique
de telles taxes bien plus élevé que les
petites marches de la plupart des
constructeurs devrait très certainement
être répercutées sur les consommateurs
rendant les véhicules plus cher
réduisant le choix et affectant la
demande
cet appel intervient au terme d'une
semaine d'intenses frictions entre
londres et bruxelles
à moins de quatre mois de l'échéance
pour conclure un deal qui conviendrait
aux deux parties la situation toujours
préoccupante sur l'île grecque de lesbos
des milliers de demandeurs d'asile r sur
l'île après les incendies qui ont
entièrement détruit les six jours le
méga camp de moria le plus grand
d'europe
les autorités en construire un nouveau
mais beaucoup de migrants refusent de
s'y installer alors que plusieurs 4
coronavirus sont signalés françois
xavier lambert ce sont plus de 300
tentes blanches installées à la hâte qui
s'étale sur cet ancien champ de tir
militaire en périphérie de mytilène la
capitale de lesbos voici le principal
camp de migrants censé héberger près de
dix mille réfugiés après les incendies
qui ont détruit le camp de moria l'armée
grecque espère pouvoir tous les heroes
loger d'ici la fin de semaine
mais beaucoup de migrants refusent de
s'installer dans la nouvelle zone
il redoute de ne pas pouvoir poursuivre
leur périple vers d'autres pays
européens
tellement et si mon ami nous n'avons pas
de quand je veux aller en allemagne
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes ici je n'ai
rien mangé
nous n'avons pas d'électricité j'attends
et je ne suis pas un étranger
je suis un réfugié afghan dans ce
nouveau quand les migrants peuvent
recevoir de la nourriture et des soins
médicaux
les autorités et les ong ne voulait
surtout pas reconstruire un camp comme
celui de moria critiqué pour sa
surpopulation et ses conditions
d'hygiène nous fournissons des produits
tels que des couvertures des tapis de
sol l'épée sacs de couchage d'hygiène et
nous fournissons également des conseils
techniques sur la planification et la
configuration du site car nous avons
cette expérience dans le monde une
hygiène plus que jamais primordial alors
que le coronavirus pourrait faire des
ravages parmi les migrants selon les
autorités grecques
au moins trente cinq d'entre eux ont été
testés positifs au kobe de 19 et placé
en quarantaine et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi dans
quelques minutes à 22 heures précisément
vous aurez rendez vous avec pierre vis à
vis
pour un point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez vous